welcome back we are here with innovator
inspiration and all-around amazing human
being Abby Lee Miller face is far apart
how dare you that's exactly what I hoped
now Abby we need to get your review of
our routine an investment yes I was
impressed to say the least I thought it
was going to be like garbage to junior
high talent show girls that never dance
today in their lives and it's just one
show could you see the story that was
being told no great cuz there was no
store yeah okay now Abby we know that
you might not choose us to be on your
team but we have some videos of dancers
that we think have great potential for
for you as students and so we'd love to
show you each a candidate that we found
on what would you know about potential I
mean I just look for charisma that's all
like this
yeah they got Krueger this one does not
pay the bills honey I've been told I've
been told by my accountant but that
unless you have a rich aunt named
charisma oh yeah and then thank you my
charisma yes she comes from a family of
weird names and usually welcome to come
to my dance studio any time it's on
camera you got that on camera she
invited teacher YouTube past
uh yes mamrie are you okay your bad
knees I know
come on okay don't sit cool
don't stick all the beats second time
insane oh geez okay so we'd love to show
you a video each and let you choose who
you'd rather have on your team okay this
is my candidate for the Abby Lee dance
company
Wow it's a lot well it's a lot but he's
obviously adorable and quick and
entertaining but what kind of stretch
does he have I mean is he flexible does
he have great feet does he know his
ballet terminology it's he versatile
okay
my candidate doesn't really have the
training but I think the heart is there
and I think if anyone could whip her
into shape it'd be you it's good that
he's got the moves yeah ladies not see
he's like me and I routine I just watch
memory for the okay you've seen both
candidates so which one of those would
you choose
neither huh let's get a move on it we
went on our Facebook page and got some
questions for you if you would delight
us with your answers well maimry I'll
let you go for sure
come up twinkle toes kite linger ooh
that is an amazing middle name yes
how long have you been involved with
dance this child should do some homework
s Kel Frazier asks what's your opinion
on the amount of drama the moms have
it's real Wow
so are people just screaming constantly
and trying to help drama the next to get
sometimes okay I have a question for you
guys yeah okay would you or would you
not egg a guy's house 100% one time in
high school I took a 30-pound thing of
egg salad and dumped it on the hood of
their car with sprinkles and it
accidentally rained and his Toyota
Tercel turned rainbow North Carolina
last question comes from its Grace and
@name town if you had to choose had to
choose between Grace and mamrie to be
new members of the ALDC who would you
choose
huh yeah that's what Abby said mother
well Abby I have to thank you so much
for being here like this should have
been more fun
how do wow how dare me I know I like
guys we should go out or something yeah
of course
okay I mean margaritas and fun that's
what we're all about Abby you have made
our dreams come true and we can't thank
you enough make sure to check out Dance
Moms if you haven't because it is one of
the greatest reality television programs
of all time I'm gonna get you out of
these shirts oh yeah my name blazing
across your bosom I think I should slip
into this for the rest of my life
done well all right listen I gotta say
one thing okay when you wear my name on
your chest
yes no joking I got no smoking okay
never no hanging at the mall with the
losers no swearing we'll be back with
Paul Scheer and hopefully some semblance
of our sanities see you in a little bit
hashtag great show this is the greatest
[ __ ] I was surprised that the one girl
maimry she has big teeth a big mouth it
works for her no the other one that
skinny little friend she's probably
gonna get all the guys but not get all
the trophies
you